after his debut in daredevil season 2
John Byrne CIL's Punisher was such a
huge hit that he got his own series and
at the end of the last episode of the
defenders was a cool post-credit teaser
for Frank Castle new solo show you
became a movie lovers it's Jan here and
in this video I'll be breaking down the
new Punisher teaser for Easter eggs and
clues on what we can expect from Jon
Bernthal upcoming series also I'm
running a Punisher and defenders
giveaway so make sure you subscribe and
leave a comment for a chance to win a
Punisher or defenders Funko pop as Jon
Bernthal previously revealed in an e w
interview The Punisher series will
heavily feature Frank castles military
background and true to this the new
teaser shows quite a bit more of castles
military past with heavy hints at some
serious conflicts he got into during a
time in the forces you can see his fists
here smash the photo of himself with his
colleagues and there's another shot
later where Castle is being held back
from assaulting this guy and if you look
closely it seems like Castle has given
him a nasty injury to his left eye I
suspect this could be the character
William Rollins he's played by Paul
Scholes II and actor best known for
roles in Nurse Jackie 24 and The
Sopranos in the comics Rollins with a
crooked CIA agent who engineered various
terrorist attacks and deliberately
abandoned his wife Catherine O'Brien in
Afghanistan
later O'Brien and Castle captured
Rollins who lost an eye while being
interrogated by castle and there's
another shot in the teaser of Rollins
with what looks like either a glass or
injured left eye confirming that some
aspect of this comic book story will
likely play out in the Punisher comic
book Rollins also had a hand in drug
smuggling so I wonder if the Punisher
series will give us any links between
him and Colonel Schoonover carful former
commanding officer who turned out to be
a major drug lord in daredevil season 2
the teaser also gives us a glimpse at
what looks like castles wife's being
shot actress Carrie Barrett has been
cast in the role of Frank's wife Maria
castle
Maria looks rather different in the
photos of Frank's family and daredevil
season 2 so it seems safe to say that
her character's been recast for the
Punisher what's even more interesting
though is that if this is Maria being
shot dead in her home this would
conflict with the story established in
daredevil in the 10th episode of season
2 da Samantha Reyes confess that Frank
castles family was killed in Central
Park when a sting operation against very
gangs weren't wrong and castles wife and
children were fatally injured in the
crossfire so what does this mean for
Maria well either there's something not
completely true about da Reyes story or
perhaps the shot in the teaser is a fake
out either a warning or threat to Frank
from someone like Roland or perhaps even
a hallucination or nightmare in castles
mind either way according to IMDB Maria
is set to appear in seven episodes and
her children implore so it looks like
we'll get to see castle spend some time
with his family in the new show for
example this shot of him with his
children sailing past the Statue of
Liberty indeed speaking with e/w Bansal
says that the Frank Castle that was in
dead level is not in Punisher so the
fact that this teaser shows us that
we'll see more of what made castle the
Punisher in other words his relationship
with his family and their fate as well
as his military past ties in well with
that and during a recent interview with
Moviefone
Burnsville talked about taking pains to
make sure Castle wasn't depicted as too
heroic in the new series proventil it
was crucial to get across just a brutal
damaged and tortured Frank is and he
wanted to make sure they explored his
pain and what's behind the violence and
the reason he's committing it speaking
of pain and torture it's not a hundred
percent clear and the scene exactly
who's being tortured could it be carful
perhaps in retaliation for what he did
to Rollins though the guy's profile
doesn't quite look like bansal's to me
or could it be a scene shown that
castles taken part in torturing this man
Jon Bernthal voice over in the teaser is
also really interesting as it suggests
that the Punisher series is going to
delve much deeper into Frank Castle
psyche in the voiceover Castle talks
about having made a deal with the devil
which ties in with Punishers origins
stories told by Garth Ennis in his
four-part comic book miniseries born in
that story it was a voice inside castles
head which helped him deal with the
horrors of the Vietnam War and that
voice which talk to Frank in the
miniseries may represent either the
devil or death in fact the chilling page
and the final issue were after Frank
returns home he sees a picture of his
own family framed inside an outline of
the Punisher skull and an inner voice
reminds him that was a price to pay this
links nicely to the line in the teaser
where Frank says he's coming he's coming
to collect that line not only for
shadows how Frank lost his own family
after returning from the war but it also
teases of vigilante justice we can
back to see Punisher dispatching to the
criminal underworld in his new series as
for the repeated image of Frank
sledge-hammering a concrete floor this
seems like it could just be footage for
the teaser trailer although it does make
me think of the scene in the first John
wick movie where he uses a sledge hammer
to break out his stash of weapons and
gold to go on the rampage against the
criminals who wronged him so what did
you think of the teaser for the Punisher
and if it got you hyped to the full
season on Netflix let me know what you
think in the comments below and also
subscribe for your chance to win a
Punisher or defenders Funko pop coming
shortly is my defenders Easter eggs
video so make sure you turn on your
notifications to get that as soon as
it's ready if you enjoyed this don't
forget to hit that thumbs up button and
leave me suggestions for future videos
as well in the meantime you can check
out some other videos you might like
right here thanks for watching and see
you next time you became movie lovers